D
MANAGE THEIR DIFFERENCES.
JOINING ME NOW IS STEPHEN MILLER
FORMER SENIOR ADVISOR TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND FORMER
DEPUTY ASSISTANT SECRETARY OF
STATE.
>> GREAT TO BE WITH YOU.
THE MAIN THING THAT NOTHING
CHANGED.
CHINA BUILD UP HAS NOT STOPPED.
CIRCULATION HAS NOT STOPPED.
THE PRESIDENT SAYING, SAYING
THERE'S NO IMMINENT THREAT.
DOES THAT TELL US COUPLE OF
MONTHS?
WHAT ABOUT NEXT YEAR?
WE ALSO KNOW THAT XI JINPING
PROMISED BARACK OBAMA THAT WE
WASN'T GOING TO MILITARIZED ON
SOUTH CHINA SEA.
HE'S NEVER COME CLEAN ON COVID.
>> Laura: STEVE, TO THAT POINT,
EVEN THOUGH THEY MET FOR THREE
HOURS, THE WHITE HOUSE REVEALED
THAT COVID WAS NOT RAISED.
THIS WAS QUESTIONS AFTER THE
WUHAN LAB AND MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS COMING TO THE
CONCLUSION THAT THIS WAS A VIRUS
THAT ORIGINATED IN THAT
LABORATORY.
NOT EVEN MENTIONED.
>> IT'S ASTONISHING THAT THEY
WOULD NOT BRING UP THE CHINESE
CORONAVIRUS THAT HAS BROUGHT
SUCH PAIN AND DEVASTATION ON
THIS WORLD AND OUR ECONOMY.
THE PRESIDENT TRUMP TOOK
ENORMOUS HEAT FOR PUSHING THE
IDEA THAT'S BEEN THOROUGHLY
PROVEN THAT THIS CAME FROM A
LABORATORY.
NOT FROM NATURE.
BIDEN HAS COMPLETELY CAPITULATED
TO XI AND CHINA FOR THEIR SINGLE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR UNLEASHING
COVID ON THE WHOLE OF THE EARTH.
IT WAS A DISGRACEFUL DAY.
>> Laura: WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT
WHERE WE ARE ECONOMICALLY, CHINA
IS DEALING WITH THEIR ISSUE WITH
THEIR ZERO COVID, WHICH IS
BRUTAL TO THE POINT OF YOU CAN'T
IMAGINE IT'S HAPPENING THERE.
I WANT TO GET YOUR RESPONSE FROM
SOMETHING THAT TOM FRIEDMAN
WROTE LAST WEEK.
WATCH.
>> U.S.-CHINA RELATIONS IS THE
CORE OF STABILITY IN THE WORLD.
ECONOMIC PROSPERITY.
WE NEED TO FIND A WAY TO
COLLABORATE WITH THEM AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE.
>> Laura: HIS HEAD IS FLOATING
IN THAT BLACKNESS THERE.
THAT'S LIKE THE BEGINNING OF
STAR STRACK.
STRANGE SHOT.
WHAT ABOUT THAT.
NOW WE SHOULD COLLABORATE.
COLLABORATING WITH A SLAVE
STATE.
WE'VE BEEN TALKING A LOT ABOUT
SLAVERY.
NOW APPARENTLY, IT'S TO
COLLABORATE WITH A SLAVE STATE.
>> XI JINPING IS A TASK FORCE
TIE.
THIS GUY IS A HARD MAN.
HE'S PREPARED TO LIE.
HE'S UNDERTAKING HISTORIC
MILITARY BUILDUP.
SAID THAT OUR MILITARY READINESS
IS SINKING.
THEY KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON.
I THINK THAT'S THE KEY THING AND
THE NOTION THAT WE'RE GOING TO
COLLABORATE AND SEGMENT OFF NICE
COLLABORATION ON THINGS THAT
THEY PREFER LIKE CLIMATE CHANGE
AND HAVE THIS CONTROL
COMPETITION LIKE ON A TENNIS
COURT.
WHEN YOU GET OFF, YOU'RE GOING
TO HAVE NICE GLASS OF ICE TEA.
AS POINTED OUT, -- WHY ARE WE
THINKING WE WILL PLACATE THEM.
OTHER THING, WHEN YOU SAW WHAT
BIDEN WAS SAYING ABOUT THE
RUSSIA AND THE NEGATIVITY.
CHINA IS TEN TIMES THE SIZE.
WHEN THEY COME TO FIGHT, THAT'S
GOING TO BE A DIFFERENT
UNIVERSE.
WE'RE ACTING IT'S JUST A
MISUNDERSTANDING.
>> Laura: EVERY TIME THEY SAY
RUSSIA, I SAY CHINA.
CHINA IS MAKING HUGE INROADS IN
AFRICA, IN ZAMBIA.
WHEN I WAS THERE, SIGNS --
>> THEY WANT TO BILL ON THE
ATLANTIC COAST OF AFRICA.
>> Laura: APPARENTLY WE SUPPOSED
TO COLLABORATE.
BOEING IS HOPING FOR GOOD NEWS
POST ELECTION BECAUSE BIDEN AND
XI ARE IN TALKS TO TALK ABOUT
TRADE.
BIG BUSINESS WANTS CHINA
BUSINESS AND IT'S NEVER GOING TO
END.
SAME WITH THE INVESTMENT BANKING
CROWD.
CHINA IS THEIR FUTURE.
THEY SEE REAL GROWTH THERE.
>> BIDEN IS THE ULTIMATE
GLOBALIST.
THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS WHY
YOU SEE THE BILL CRYSTAL'S OF
THE WORLD JOIN THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY.
THAT'S THE HOME OF GLOBALISM AND
THIS ONE WORLD GARBAGE THAT WILL
DESTROY OUR COUNTRY.
THAT'S WHY BIDEN DIFFERENT STAND
UP ON CHINESE TRADE, POLLUTION
AND FENTANYL AND HE DIDN'T STAND
UP TO SINGLE SOLITARY AMERICAN
INTEREST.
THEY WANT A GREATER ECONOMIC
MERGER WITH CHINA.
>> Laura: THEIR U.S. TRADE REP,
IT'S PROBABLY THEIR TRADE REP
WHO HELL THE LINE PRETTY WELL ON
TRUMP'S TARIFFS.
I HOPE XI WINS OUT IN THIS
DEBATE.
>> WE'LL SEE.
LOT OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY, LOT
OF THIS IS REPRESENTING THESE
INTERESTS NOW.
I THINK IT'S CRITICAL THAT
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS WHO
AGREE HOLD THE LINE.
IT'S NOT IN THE INTEREST OF
WORKING AMERICANS.
THAT'S WHY POLICY ABOUT CHINA IS
CRITICAL TO GET IT RIGHT.
IF CHINA WILL DOMINATE THE WORLD
AND OUR ECONOMY, IT'S GOING TO
BE MUCH WORSE.
THERE WILL BE PEOPLE WHO
BENEFIT.
>> I NEVER SAW A GLOBALIST TRADE
DEAL HE DIDN'T LOVE.
>> L